We Didn't Start by trying to raise any
money at all we just wanted to raise
awareness I just wanted people to know
that they should check themselves for
breast cancer monthly that was more more
than I could ask for and yet by doing
these small events suddenly it turned
into events that people wanted to pay
for and they were willing to hand over
you know up to fifty dollars for an
event as a student is a lot of money so
it was really kind of like for lack of
cliche terminology it was like a pupil
power movement like that's what grew it
and that's what continues to grow it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders this one is about impact and how
companies are making social impact with
regards to ESG meet Nina Rauch at age 16
she founded a breast cancer charity in
memory of her late mother that sparked
her passion for social impact and making
a dent in the universe her campaign has
since raised over half a million dollars
including almost fifty thousand dollars
in under an hour and spread Nationwide
2018 she joined the ensure Tech lemonade
to lead social impact in ESG she has
distributed over 4 million dollars in
donations to over a hundred partner
organizations and the impact has grown
four thousand percent higher she was
named one of the 100 women to watch by
Barclays and is written for the
telegraph guardian and Forbes
you know they say the world is changing
quickly
um and the way that you're impacting
people's lives throughout your work at
lemonade but also also throughout the
different initiatives that you've that
you've founded and organized that it's
pretty remarkable and and so I I want to
unwrap in these 20 minutes a little bit
about how your your brain thinks through
impact social impact ESG lemonade and
the different you know
fundraising and building organizations
that make a positive impact and so Nina
take me all the way back to to being 16
you're creating your first you know real
big impact in the world what's going on
there and and what is the driving force
for you to then become an impact leader
throughout your career
definitely so I lost my mother to breast
cancer when I was around 14 years old
and it really motivated me to see that
there was probably a different way of
approaching impact and charitable giving
that was traditionally done by
non-profits because my thinking as a 16
year old was if I wasn't being targeted
by a non-profit and yet I needed to be
aware of breast cancer from a young age
and probably so many of my peers were in
the same position so I thought let's
start to rethink impact and giving back
and make it much more accessible trendy
relatable for Gen Z and Millennials so I
launched an initiative called pink week
which became kind of a nationwide breast
cancer campaign raised hundreds and
thousands of dollars made up from five
dollar donations and all from people
around the ages of 16 to 25 Max wow so
really we think yeah it really made me
think that the way that we're
approaching impact hand and who we
should be engaging with it is wrong it
should correlate both with audience and
the consumer and that just kind of kicks
on in my journey into just doing
something that I love and I care about
wow and so tell me about you know sort
of
just the starting of this campaign in
this organization you raised I think a
few dozen thousands of dollars just very
early on and then you know another
hundreds of thousands throughout the
last few years so what happened there
it really just spiraled naturally and I
think that's like the greatest proof
that I have that this method of young
donors works because we didn't start by
trying to raise any money at all we just
wanted to raise awareness I just wanted
people to know that they should check
themselves for breast cancer monthly
that was more more than I could ask for
and yet by doing these small events
suddenly it turned into events that
people wanted to pay for and they were
willing to hand over you know up to
fifty dollars for an event as a student
is a lot of money
um and so we realized that we were onto
something and it started to spiral and
grow from campus to campus and was
picked up completely organically by
other University students who wanted to
host it at their own campuses so it was
really kind of like for lack of cliche
terminology was like a people power
movement like that's what grew in and
that's what continues to grow it
um and then eventually we also partnered
with a larger non-profit called breast
cancer now that kind of oversees along
of the work but yeah it essentially
spread all by itself and people were
just you know wanting to talk about a
warning to tap into something and
wanting to be passionate about something
and I think they just hadn't been given
the opportunity to do that previously
phenomenal and so if you're looking at
um you know your work today as a leader
in social impact with eliminated someone
will get into the some of the the really
amazing things you've done there with
with the partners it will sort of is
that the connecting line back to when
you were 16 and and creating that that
charity is that sort of your that was
that your initial inspiration and
motivation for becoming an impact leader
throughout your career definitely I
think the line is super clear because
what it went from was being 16 and 20
and talking about non-profit work and
you know social impact with my age group
and my peers to then working for a
startup where your audience is very
similar you know you're targeting gen Z
and Millennials you want to get them
excited about your products and a huge
part of that is social impact
um you know we know that I think up to
85 of Millennials and gen Z would rather
purchase and work for a company that
cares about giving back than one that
doesn't so there's a direct connection
between who you know the same people
that I was working with with pink week
to the people that we work with today at
lemonade
um which is incredible to see I I really
didn't believe that it was possible to
find a job that was as impactful as as
the one that I have is so it's it's a
real privilege incredible so you've
distributed
um millions of dollars to more than 100
partner organizations and you know just
from the buyer you mentioned that the
your the impact of the organization has
grown basically four thousand percent
um well what is it that you do really in
lemonade so at lemonade we have our
social impacts and I think it falls onto
around four categories we have a huge
focus on the environmental and climate
we've donated around 815
um to around 17 climate organizations
since 2017 and we also are very focused
on the climate by our part product we
have environmentally friendly car
insurance and we took a stance against
investing in fossil fuels but we also
have our give back program which is
where we partner with non-profit to
donate unclean premiums at the end of
the insurance year and this is really
kind of what has driven forward our
social impact from the very beginning
and I would say our social impact has
grown around the give back because it's
very natural that once you start working
with these non-profit Partners you know
you'll make adaptions within your
product that will reflect the social
impact stance and the Charities that
you're working with externally also
internally so although give back is a
huge part of what we do and it's not our
only aspect of social impact and I think
that's really important for every
company to remember you know it's more
than just giving money back it's are you
also making sure that you're a good
company an ethical company you treat
your employees well so that's what being
a b Court which is kind of a stamp of
being a good company that's why it's so
important to us to also make sure that
we hold on to that certification so
that's a big part of what I do as well
and what what is the motivation for this
at the end I mean obviously I get it we
all want to be great people I'm all for
impact I'm you know I I do a lot of
impact investing myself but but I'm
curious how does a company like lemonade
or your team how do you get to a point
where you're so committed to to driving
impact within a company that who who's
you know positioned perhaps in the in
the ensure Tech space it's not
necessarily
you know what the one to one with
thinking through impact and and charity
if you will yeah no definitely I think
that's the amazing thing about lemonade
is that you wouldn't expect and ensure
Tech or any kind of startup to be as
impactful as they have been and I think
the real motivation is that there was
almost no underlying motivation at all
it's not that we're trying to
um bring in new customers or do
something super smart and trying to
trick anyone it's very authentic it's
just people who wanted to do good and
create a product
um that does good and makes a difference
and I actually think that's the key
because if your impact isn't authentic
then your consumer will seem right
through that it's safe you know it's
just an add-on or it's something you're
doing in order to make you buy what you
know the product that you're producing I
think consumers me and you we're small
we we can see through that when it comes
to a company so it has to be authentic
it has to be true to who you are as a
brand and I think that's what lemonade
does so well because give back was down
from the very beginning it wasn't
something that happened as an
afterthought it was built into this
product or we even launched I mean we're
a vehicle from 2016 before we've even
sold our first policy so impact was kind
of like integral to the brand before the
brand became anything else
um and I think that's the real key to
successful impact
so take me through a little bit about
the internal process that you have you
know partners that you work with where's
this money coming from you know how does
this thing fit into a a comp a publicly
traded company and you like you're
mentioning this is the system that
you've been working on you know way
before this you know this blew up as a
huge as what lemonade is
um you know how what is sort of the
internal process here yeah so anybody
who signs up for lemonade they get to
choose a give back cause to donate their
unclaimed premium to at the end of the
year and you can select from over a
hundred plus non-profits in all the
countries that we're live in and this
will be your course that you will donate
to year on year out and then every year
we will gather the funds and we will run
through it without Charities choose the
designated projects making sure that we
know where every single dollar goes
um so that we can verify that impact and
feed that back to our customers and we
work with Incredible organizations
350.org they're the largest climate
Grassroots organization out there and
launched for our lives is a gun
prevention a gun violence prevention
charity cure Childhood Cancer is a
cancer charity working to support young
child cancer patients a huge range of
non-profits and you know the incredible
thing about give back is we work with
small organizations like save the Bay
it's a very knowledge organizations like
the American Red Cross and we don't
distinguish as long as they're a good
charity and we know that they're doing
the best that they can and their you
know a legal charity of course and
tickle our regulatory boxes then we will
make sure that you know we can give as
much impact to them as possible
and so there just to make you understand
sort of the the aligned incentive here
is that if we can
if we can create trust with a mechanism
of give back where we actually show our
customers that that the underutilized
premiums are actually going to a charity
of their choice rather than
perhaps the lemonade then both you're
giving back to the community you're also
creating trust with your users but it's
and that's beautiful still there must be
you know some process of of how do you
even know which Charities to offer I
mean guess some some Charities just like
businesses are a more efficient with
their with their funding or less
efficient with their funding do you have
any consideration or does that even come
into play yeah we want to make sure that
our consumers can trust us it's really
important to me especially as someone
who is leading on the social impact
front that every charity that's
available on our app has been properly
vented they have a long list of
regulatory forms that they need to send
in that our legal team will check make
sure that they align with our brand so
they're not involved in any scandals
that you know I will take any Stoners
that we can't stand behind as a company
like that's so important to me because
you want to make sure that as a customer
you're providing you know the best
Charities available and that we can make
sure that we know exactly where every
impact goes so yeah we definitely you
know try and work with as many Charities
as possible but only the good one
I love that no I mean I think that you
know one of the big questions that I
think coming in from my end as an impact
investor is you know trying to figure
out how to measure what a dollar that I
give how is that going to be translated
to tangible impact and I think that as
you're working with many many partners
it's an interesting thought experiment
to see okay how do we how can we create
a strategy for for working with the most
efficient uh
most efficient Charities but but I want
to I want to take this back to sort of
your your own Journey you know if you're
looking at the work that you're doing
now with lemonade how does this tie into
your own personal fulfillment for for
what you want to be doing in this world
yeah I mean I never thought that I would
end up working for an insurance company
yeah well for a non-profit I thought
that was the only way that I could make
an impact and then similar to you you
just spoke about impact investing I
started to learn a lot more about the
benefit Corporation model the B Corp
model what it meant to be a for-profit
that kind of had impact at its core and
I really understood that this is
actually a way to maximize impact
um and like you know like you said you
want to know exactly where the money is
going we every time pre or give back we
run impact reports where we work with
the charity to break down every single
dollar so we know exactly where your
money is going
um and I think that was something that
was really important for me is that when
I started to look for the job that I
wanted to end up in I had to think
outside the books a little bit you know
did I want to stay within the non-profit
sector or was there a way to create
maximum impacts at a different kind of
company
um and I actually just looked up being
corpse in Israel when I was looking for
work and at the time I think there were
only three lemonade yeah
and I knew I wanted to work for a b Corp
and so that's how I came to Lemonade I
really fell in love with the business
model
um and I yeah I mean it really seemed
too good to be true but having been
there for up to four years now I know
that the impact is as good as they make
it sound it's genuine it's authentic and
it's really it's true impact
I love it so so I'd love to spend the
last five minutes we have you know
talking a little bit more strategically
about how do we take this or the lessons
that you've learned and sort of play
them out for an industry or an
ecosystem-wide how do we take
traditional companies and figure out how
to create sort of these creative give
back Solutions or these win-win
situations in which the profitability of
the company is directly aligned with the
the positive impact it creates on
society
yeah definitely well I think the first
thing that every company should do is
take a look internally and say what do
my employees care about and what do my
consumers care about is there something
that we align on is lgbtq Plus or the
climate is that something that stands
true for us as a company and then how
can we take practical steps to then show
our commitment outside of that is it
monetary donations is it volunteering we
work with deed which is a um a very cool
you know volunteer platform that helps
our employees give back so that's
another way that we kind of integrate
impacts into our day-to-day and I think
that's something that every company can
do even if it's just one volunteer day
you know a year I think a long way and
the same same you know partnering with
one charity that really speaks to you or
speaks to your team is a really easy way
to just kind of enter into the impact
space it's just small steps I mean the
gift that started in 2017 around fifty
thousand dollars and now we've done 6
six million dollars in six years so step
by step it's grown into something
incredibly substantial and we never
underestimated the power of a micro
donation which kind of goes back to what
we were saying you know when I was 16
and I realized that five dollar
donations can go a long way it's the
exact same message I give back and so my
biggest advice would be don't
underestimate the power of the small
donation because it's stable it's
consistent it will build impact over
time and I think that's a real key to
driving impact to other companies
so what I'm hearing you say is that
there is um a lot it's it's important to
give room to this idea that it's not a
it's not a zero-sum game you know it's
incremental changes in any incremental
positive movement in the impact space
you're you know you're you're doing well
and and it's going to continue growing
I'm curious how how much of this is
ingrained in sort of a company's culture
rather than a separate unit within the
company that's sort of in charge of this
impact side and then the rest of the
company is perhaps aligned or not
aligned with what's happening what have
you been observing to be helpful should
the whole company be involved with this
impact conversation or should it be a
designated team that just deals with it
what's the best yeah it's a great
question I think impact when it lies at
the core of a brand has to touch on
every team especially when it's a key
part of the product you can't really
separate it from what lemonade is that's
a you know my experience on the inside
so for example you know we our designers
and under developers work on our impact
reports and they're super excited to do
so and we produce these beautiful
reports I recommend everyone go check
them out and so that shows like the
collaboration kind of across the teams
and the same goes you know we did a
company-wide volunteering during give
back this year you know really makes a
key part of why people come and work at
laminators because they know they can
work at a firm that is excited about
impact I have employees messaging me the
whole time suggesting Charities you know
telling me about charitable days or
volunteer days that they've got planned
and I think there's a real feeling of
excitement around impact and it's
something that like I know as a
millennial or gen Z like I look for that
when I want to you know apply for a job
and I know my friends look for it as
well so I think it's really important
that it's not just sitting in one team
but it's really company-wide
phenomenal I I love it now it you know
you're if you're thinking throughout
your your own journey and again look
extending sort of this train of thought
or this this connecting dots whoa you
know where do you see yourself what is
your vision for yourself
in in the impact that you want to make
in the world do you have some some sort
of place you want to get to or some
vision for where what stem or what Mark
you want to leave here because it sounds
like you're very Vision oriented in your
in your journey
yeah definitely I think to see someone
leading social impact that every company
would be the dream I think if you can
have social impact embedded in every
product I mean that's really what we
should be seeing that should be a much
fine you know finer line than we already
see between for-profit and non-profit
collaboration
um and that would be my vision just to
kind of keep growing the social impact
sector especially in Israel it's growing
a lot recently
um but making people much more aware of
it would be the best thing I love it
Nina thank you so much for your time and
for the great impact that you're making
and within lemonade but the inspiration
in general so thank you very much and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you so
much thanks for having me
thank you very very much
[Music]